well Hans welcome back to the show you
tweeted before the round it's time to
let the chess speak for itself did the
chess Pi for itself in this
game
no tell us about the game HS how do you
feel about the result how do you feel
about all this Dynamic play that you
guys have been engaging in for the last
few
hours yeah I think um the only moment
that I'm really thinking about is uh
when I played
U Queen F5 I think a full Rook sacrifice
with Knight takes G5 there uh might have
been winning or that's it that's that's
what I'm that's what I've been thinking
about you actually wanted to play that
move you were half a second the way you
uh hinted at touching that pawn and
picking it off the board yeah I just
hesitated uh I
wanted yeah I thought that um Queen F5 I
could never lose nine takes G5 was
obviously some risk